本日は少しばかりかマーケティングについ
てお話しさせてください
私は8歳の時
ある cm に憧れて仮面ライダーの変身
ベルトを誕生日に買ってもらいました
当時の私はこのベルトを手に入れることに
よってあの cm の男の子みたいにため
平に変身
悪党を倒せるのではと思っていました
13歳の
私は初めてキャンメイクで
コスマを買いました
当時の私はパーティレッドになっている
ようなモデルさんみたい
あの切符を手に入れることで可愛くなれる
のでは
かすかな期待を抱いていました
このようにマーケティングの思うつぼに
なりながらもマーケティングや痛み費等を
魅了するにさせるのかに興味を持った私は
高校1年生の時から少しずつですが
マーケティングの勉強を始めま
皆さんもご存知の通りマーケティングとは
人の購買力をアップさせん
ターゲットの相対化とかこんなにたいなど
といった理想像を停止
2商品を購入することであたかもその理想
と一緒に得ることができるのかのように
錯覚させるものだと思っています
不要なものでもマーケティングを通じて
理想的に店を合わせ経済を促す
それなりの経済活動思うのではない
でしょうか
市産業革命以降
私たちの暮らしは本当に豊かなものへと
なりました
私たちは欲しいものは大概お金を払えば手
に入れることができます
地球のエネルギーや資源を搾取し成長品を
作り
そして販売し使い終わったら廃棄する
しかしそんな社会の限界がやってきて
しまいました
現在はさしてラブの時代エコの時代
ミニマリストの時代といわれています
これはどういうことが本当に必要なもの
だけを買ってそれが多く長く大切に使う私
はそういうものだった海賊しています
言って今まで通りのマーケティングは時代
にそぐわなくなってきてしまいました
そしてそれと同時にグリーンウォッシュ
などといった問題も露わになってきました
グリーンを人は本当は環境に配慮してない
プロダクトやブランドについて
マーケティングを通じているエコであるん
だとか環境にやさしいなどといった間違っ
た認識を与えるこういうことです
私たち消費者はこのグリーンウォッシュの
せいで間違った認識のもと消費活動を行っ
ています
誇張や立割によって経済活動を促す
それを間違っています私たちは真実を知る
べきます
真実を知った上でいるの封入するべきなん
だ
それではどうやって真実を伝えるべきなん
でしょうか
その答えが一方的にものを購入するのでは
なくてそのに作り上げるということだと
思っています
その代表的なで手づくりワークショップ
皆さんはいたことがありますでしょうか
私はそれが大好きで今までに
snowdome ワークショップだっ
たりキャンドルワークショップ
汗最近では誰ままで作ってみました
やはり人間はただ誰かが作った既製品出来
じゃなくてだけではなくて自分た使った
自分が一生懸命作ったものに価値を見出し
ます
そこで考えました
手作りワークショップを使ってマーケてみ
たできるのではないか
そして開催してみましたアクセサリー
手作りワークショップです
現在私はへのいやといって捨てるという
概念をしているを啓発するための団体を
運営しています
そしてその活動の一環として
改良の目から作るアクセサリー
ワークショップの運営を行いました
結果大成功でした
ある5歳の男の子カイト君って言うんです
けどその子が1日に3回も遊びに来てくれ
て
そしてしまいにはカタコトな言葉で捨てる
という概念をしているという言葉を覚えて
帰ってきてくれました
あまり一緒に作るということを通じて
作り上げる過程で理念やストーリーについ
て知ってもらいたい私はそう考えました
今までのマーケティングは誇張や逸話に
よって人々の購買力を流してきました
しかしここではあると一緒に作り上げると
いうことを通じて捨てるという概念をして
いるこれを啓発することができました
理想の経済活動とはこういったことなので
はないでしょうか
そして現在は食品宅配会社の新規ビジネス
の立ち上げに携わらせていただいています
ここでも私たちは一緒に作るということを
大事にしています
こんなビジネスでは各家庭から出る色入り
つまり揚げ物をあぴたんとに出るあの廃油
を回収しそこから洗剤を作りその洗剤を
また各派テーマで宅配するというものを
行っています
そしてそのサービスではできた潜在序盤の
好きな香りを入れることができます
自分のか好きな香りを入れることによって
もっと洗剤は月になればっ
スキーになったからこそもっと知りたく
なるそしてすることによって好調偽りの
マーケティングに惑わされなくなるのでは
ないでしょうか
私たちの消費で社会は変わる
皆さんはこの言葉をご存知でしょうか
体がここにいる皆さん一人一人が真実や
理念を大切にする企業で商品を買うとする
の子とそんな企業を応援していることに
つながります
そんな企業が増えることで私たちは真実を
知ることができる
何よりサステナブルな社会とつながるので
はないでしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございました